commencement
is the signature event on the mit campus
so then to be asked to create the
opening music video to this big event
also knowing that tens of thousands of
people
were gonna be ready and waiting to watch
this
live that was a real honor and a real
privilege
[Music]
there's a big dream with this piece i
remember when fred first told us about
this piece
he was like everyone's going to be in it
every single person we could possibly
get
is going to be in this piece and fred a
man of big ideas
we're talking about marshalling 200
people
it was a little crazy
it wasn't just going to be jasmine it
was going to be the vocal jazz ensemble
it was going to be a cappella groups it
was going to be mitzo it was going to be
wind ensemble it was going to be quiet
[Music]
my first thought was wow this is going
to be such an epic way to
celebrate commencement
[Music]
the lyrics from the piece were taken
from poetry submitted by mit students
the tone of it was really personal a lot
of it
kind of achingly painful and difficult
but with glimmers of hope and sense of
trying to prevail
trying to overcome the challenges of the
pandemic
i felt very much that that was
reflective of our pandemic
experience it started out really tough
and by the time
that we were recording this we were
flourishing
[Music]
we're going to acknowledge the
seriousness and the devastation
that the pandemic has caused at the same
time we're going to try to learn from
this experience
and not just go back to normal because
there is no
more going back to normal
being outside in the stata amphitheater
and playing trumpet alongside the
festival jazz ensemble
it was an awesome experience because i
actually hadn't really
played with people like live for
an entire year basically there was a
certain
energy that everyone had because we
finally got to see
everybody together in the same place
playing together
it felt like a great send-off sort of to
our
senior year
[Music]
it was pretty amazing that they moved a
piano and
drum kit outside the stata a beautiful
upright piano being able to play on the
real instrument made such a difference
i want the music video to bring
something to the music
that isn't there by just hearing the
song
[Music]
if you're able to cut to a certain
instrumentalist at a certain time
you're drawing the listener to hearing
such a
booming instrument that comes in right
at that time
[Music]
what i wanted to do in the shooting is
to have an improvisational aspect to it
so that all the camera people present
could really use their eyes and ears to
frame
what looked like the right thing to see
at that time
jam sheet i think is really good when it
comes to writing for guitar he really
gets what makes guitar song good and
so he has his own guitar and he sent the
video of him playing the part
hey sebastian there's probably other
ways to play the chords but this sounded
good to me on a dadgad tuning
so you'll make this thing right okay
thanks man
[Music]
it's using what we call an open tuning
so we detune the strings of the guitar
to be able to play different chords and
the whole guitar sounds different when
you do that
a good guitar part can be really fun to
play and this is definitely one of those
such a climactic moment in the music
notice what you play music for
moments like those
[Music]
the music department has given so much
to me in terms of experiences
and friendships so it was really great
to be able to represent music at mit
through this performance
[Music]
[Laughter]
you